if you make if you make a a story you
know donald trump is bad donald trump
throws a bag of puppies over a bridge
people can be like oh no you do a story
donald trump runs into burning
building to save box of puppies prove it
that's not true
that's unverified i don't believe it the
fire wasn't even that hot tim
yeah come on it was barely hot so well
the the the
the joke i made before is that they'll
find a way to make it negative yeah like
donald trump
he is the president of the united states
should not be risking his life
and this country for puppies we all love
puppies but it was irresponsible they'll
find some way to make it yeah
but anyway the point is i talked about
it before with covid
if the story about kovit is that it's
the end of the world you're totally fine
if the story about kovid is that there's
hope they ban you they shut you down
so it's like whatever this establishment
is they can only say
one thing that aligns with their
acceptable narrative
i wonder if there's not really an
establishment of like you know corrupt
people who are
you know wealthy and in power as much as
it is a bunch of people pointing guns at
each other scared
you know like the the idea being if i
actually admit how i feel i'll get
canceled so i better join the mob and
cancel them so no one finds out
but in reality everybody secretly agrees
they hate what's going on
but they've trapped themselves i think
that you're probably right there's a lot
of people that are afraid of
uh the repercussions of standing up
and and saying no i don't think i don't
think that i agree with that and
you know like i said i'm not like a i'm
not like a pro trump guy
you're not gonna find you know maga 2020
or whatever on
on anything that that i put out i'll
criticize trump
um without hesitation if he does
something stupid the
the other day when he put up the joe
biden meme where joe biden was in a
uh an old age home you're already
laughing i thought i did
i laughed i i can't i know it's like i
think the guy's a clown like
trump is hilarious he's a clown wait
wait it was biden for residents
and it was joe in a nursing home
i think it's funny that trump does that
stuff i mean
trump is a s poster and and i think it's
great
i think it's hilarious um i know that it
makes people mad
and they'll get over it but uh but
you know it's dumb and it that's what it
is and it's probably not a good idea for
the president to be doing it
aside from the fact that you know people
like me laugh about it
but it's it's probably not a good idea
um so i you know i criticized
criticizing for that you trump shouldn't
be doing this this is dumb or whatever
but
because i don't hate donald trump enough
and because i'm i i'm like well you know
i'm critical when he deserves it i'm i'm
probably like ben shapiro in the fact
that
you know super speer has the good trump
bad trump thing that he does so i have
no problem being like trump's a bad you
know trump did this wrong or i don't
agree with that
um but it's people that stand up and and
stick their head up you know those
those people will get you know get their
yeah outside i think you're right i
think there are a lot of people who are
secretly pro-trump
pretending to be an sjw like they'll
tweet saying like oh trump is bad
and then they're deep down like i'm
gonna go vote for trump because i can't
live this way anymore
they're they're scared of getting
canceled we had that cato institute poll
62 percent of people are scared to speak
their minds the only uh
the only there's strong liberal liberal
center
conservative strong conservative the
only one of those that felt comfortable
expressing their opinions was strong
liberal strong
lib strong liberal far left i mean
i like liberalism i like free people i
like liberty
i don't like communism you know
like strong liberals
i draw the line at like american left
versus
international left american left cool
but yeah this is the crazy thing
when when cato says strong liberal you
know they don't mean liberal in any way
do you think they mean communist they
mean far left progressive
because like that's just how they worded
it i mean
connectivist yeah yeah more it's it's so
weird how liberal
came to mean collectivist in many ways
in the u.s con
in the u.s context yes but that's why i
mentioned
internationally when you start to really
kind of
read about political philosophies you
know as well as anyone else that like
you know probably and i mentioned
property rights early property rights
are
foundational to uh
to the u to the u.s you know uh to the
to the u.s
mindset i guess um and i think that the
fact that people on the very far
left don't acknowledge that you should
have property rights
that's where the biggest problem for me
comes up you know i can
i can get into okay i understand why
people would want to have
um progressive taxation or i understand
why people would want to have
uh you know safety nets i understand why
people would want to have
uh some kind of universal health care
even though i don't think that it's it's
a good idea i think i understand why
i don't understand why people want to
say
you cannot own your home or a business
or any kind of property that you can
create things with it's simple uh i i've
noticed something
at least uh anecdotally because i've
covered a bunch of
you know a lot of these civil unrest
stories around the world starting with
the us
occupy moving through the countries the
protests in venezuela when i was there
was the rich people that were protesting
really
yeah because the government was taking
their stuff away from them
and impoverishing them and so they got
mad in
other countries it's the poor that's
protesting so
that it tends to be in like venezuela
where they were enacting all the
socialist policy it was the middle to
upper class that were angry and coming
out in the streets and you know
protesting about it
but uh it's really simple as to why they
don't want you to have properties
because they don't have any
it's that simple so they're not losing
anything that's such an
ugly way to to
i guess existing society let's let's
play some some communist scenario games
because i was
i was tweeting once and the great the
the the socialist workers party of great
britain or whatever
oh that that that's the yeah that's one
of the most clowned on twitter accounts
out there i love it good for them for
really believing it though because they
they keep coming back for more man so
good on them
it's gotta be a parody account now like
i can't belie so so listen listen
i tweeted something like we had a long
exchange where the gist of it was
if we're in a socialist system how do
you draw the distinction between private
property and personal property
they like to say there's no one should
be allowed private property and i'm like
so i can't have like my clothes no no no
that's personal property
okay so what's the difference where do
you draw the line there's no answer
there's no way to so i i asked this i
have a camera
it's a small little camera i use it to
produce videos
does it qualify as the means of
production some people say yes some
people say no there's no answer yeah but
when i was talking to
the uh the socialist party of great
britain or whatever was funny i we got
into a conversation where i basically
said something like
if i want to like build a car because i
have
enjoy working on cars how would i do
that in a socialist or communist system
where my job is you know
told to me essentially or maybe i chose
a job maybe i decided i really want to
be an accountant but you know what
it's really fun to work on cars and i
want a hobby they responded with
well it's really simple you would just
work on a car i was like well how do i
get the car
you would just go to the plant and say
you wanted you wanted a car and you'd
get it
and i was like but other people want
cars too
and they're like right but you can just
go there and get it and i'm like no no
there's a thing called scarcity
they don't believe in scarcity amazing
they don't i had i had someone tell me
you really believe that scarcity exists
and i was like uh
i know for a fact it does because like
i've been around the world and i know
that
there's places with no food and they're
like no
there is food it's just artificially
kept from them we throw away so much
food i'm like that that's not that
doesn't mean you don't understand
i i feel like that i feel like the con
the communist and socialist more
communists
to be if i'm if i'm being accurate
because i think there's a lot of people
that misunderstand what socialism is and
and
uh they don't realize that socialism
leads to community you know lenin said
the end result or the end goal of
socialism
is communism i don't think that they
realize that
life is more complex than they seem to
think
uh no matter how much food we produce in
the u.s
and no matter how much we throw away
the inefficiency or the inability to
efficiently
distribute that food around the world is
going to mean that some of that food's
going to go bad and it won't get to
people and blah blah
and just getting food to people in
places that are very far away it's like
it's not as easy as just oh we can make
it and it'll just
show up there i love the idea of uh
what is it fully automatic luxury
communism yes
yeah sounds amazing if that if like if
you can come up with a star trek
replicator right exactly fine i'm on
board yeah
right now to be honest even that's now
no way probably not
so they always say this to me like don't
you want a star trek future
and i'm like yeah they have replicators
bro yeah like they literally go
computer uh earl was it t earl grey grey
yeah
yeah yeah there you go and then it's
just like it appears there yeah they can
they can
teleport themselves they can replicate
replicators not there yet yeah okay
that's post scarcity dude
but even even the star trek world isn't
communist no they get they all they have
credits and you know the ferengi were
were always after latinum and them
that's right i love dayton i love deep
space nine yeah yeah yeah
yeah good show so but but in on in the
federation
it was there that people always say it
was communist but it's not
communist there was still you had to
earn things you had to make your own
things you when you joined you
you had to earn your skills and then you
could choose to join certain jobs
you could freely move you could freely
quit starfleet there was no mandatory
service none of that
didn't picard have a vineyard yeah
that's property
exactly you know so they just ah they
they
it's it's kids who live in a fantasy
world they don't understand the harsh
realities of the world
and i think that's why so many of these
communist and socialist uh activists are
young people
because they haven't actually ever
experienced what it's like to be outside
of the bubble
i'll i'll put it this way could you
imagine
what rockefeller would say if he was
transported
just like as like you know at the peak
of his wealth he just appeared right now
i think he'd be freaked out that oil was
destroying the ecosystem no it wasn't
i think it would be i think if you
realize how how destructive it is like
the fracking and just the extraction has
become
he would rethink what he did i don't
think so i mean foreign
no the what i'm talking about is he was
the he was the oil baron
he was like the richest guy ever or not
even let's do a better example
i don't know the names of anybody behind
the east india trading company but that
was like the biggest company in
existence at the time back what year was
the east india trading 1700s
imagine taking any one of these people
the wealthiest people in the world
and bringing them now and bringing them
to a low-income housing project
i don't have to throw my poop out the
window yeah right
great what even the poor people can just
go in the little room and it goes away
clean drinking water yeah air
conditioning refrigeration
air conditioning is a big one i tell you
what not to get off on a tangent but
europe
doesn't know that doesn't know about ac
dude i was i was in the uk i'll tell you
what and i was i was going to be
speaking an event
they booked me at a hotel on the fourth
floor of this hotel
all the heat was rising and it was like
high 80 degrees in my hotel room
and so i asked them do you have a fan i
can crack the window and blow some air
and they're like what's the problem and
i was like it's like 89 degrees in my
room i'm
i'm profusely sweating dying and they're
like oh okay we'll see if we can figure
something out they found me a fan
i got my fan i was like okay so i
decided you know i'm gonna take i'm
gonna take a bath and chill and maybe
like you know
regular body temperature i turned the
water on the water was boiling when it
came out
i was like what are what are these
people are they like fire demons they
can like yeah what is this
anyway anyway for like 15 minutes in
england
yeah correct me if i'm wrong correct me
if i'm wrong i will i heard there's a
statue to the guy who invented air
conditioning in miami there is
yeah wow yeah i need to look it up but
they're going to exist
people have said the reason why
community has diffused in the united
states why we don't hang out with our
neighbors as much as because of air
conditioning no
in south america they'll hang out
outside on the front porch that kind of
makes sense yeah
i could see it yeah conditioning i tell
you what
the uh in dogma the movie by kevin smith
the the scene where jason lee walks into
the room into the house and
turns the air conditioning up and just
uh you know i
i i feel that in my bones no exquisite
sin
greater than central air perfect i love
it i love it kevin smith's great
so anyway to to you know now that we're
done making fun of this was this guy he
invented
okay do you find it john gory oh yeah
there's a statue of the guy who
invented air conditioning in miami he
seems pretty
you're cool thank you everyone is it is
it because today but is it because he
invented air conditioning
i was told it was because i lived in
miami for a year let's look him up
when you when you're in miami and in the
summer
every window is dripping with
condensation from the air conditioning
on the inside and the humidity on the
outside
and no one goes outside yeah yeah it's
101
and humid yes and and like the
thunderstorms are awesome though
like the tropical storms it's like man
it's cool it's just like like you're
gonna die and you're like
yeah it's great but you're fine yeah
anyway the point is
our poor people are overweight yeah yeah
it's
like so i think we we do have some kind
of problem with
regulation and i don't mean regulation
in terms of law i mean like regulating
resources in certain ways so we have
homeless people who are overweight
and we have poor people who have clean
drinking water and air conditioning
but not you know lack of access to other
other resources
the point i'm trying to make is when
they say things like abolish poverty and
you know poverty shouldn't exist i'm
like
well if we base everything off of that
like 1900 there is no poverty at all
except i guess homelessness but even
then homeless people are overweight so
it's like a weird sugar that addictive
sugar
yeah yeah we could even we could do
something about the sugar industry
i would love to get rid of corn
subsidies yes there is no reason to have
corn subsidies and have
high fructose corn syrup and everything
it is a it is a
terrible policy in my opinion and i
would love to have
sugarcane coca-cola available in in
the lower 48 as well yeah well hold on
hold on why is there sugar and
everything
i wouldn't mind addictive it makes money
you know what i like doing you take a
little shot of lemon juice put in club
soda
tastes great is it it tastes great
cinnamon's a little sugar in it
yeah it like extracts the sugar that's
already in your body into your taste
buds
i mean i i'm a black coffee drinker you
know no sugar no
you know anything so i mean i i
i fully agree that we don't need to have
sugar in everything
it's probably why we have so much
diabetes why we have so many overweight
people uh yup
it's like the tobacco industry of the
day there's peddling it to kids
with commercials and cartoon characters
like they used to in like the 50s with
tobacco
i'm just over a year off of nicotine i
smoked for a long long long time so
i that kind of that kind of getting
people hooked on stuff
i i take issue with it uh so if
if we could do something to remedy that
i'd be awful
as a libertarian how do you kind of go
into that kind of
do you use utilize government
regulations how do you feel about those
um i don't
claim to know enough about
most situations to say this is what
should or shouldn't be done but i do
think
generally as a rule you get better
results
when it's done uh privately for for
for most issues there are certain things
that i think that you can't do
uh in the in the private in in the
private marketplace but i think that
most things are
are better left to uh to private
industry so
as for regulation on um you know corn
subsidies
i don't understand why we're paying
people to either make you know grow corn
or
paying people to not grow corn yeah they
pay people to not
right following fallow i don't know much
about it but i know that they do pay to
keep
uh you know keep um fields empty and
stuff sometimes
so i don't know the ins and outs of it
i'm not i'm not
in any way an expert and i and anything
that i say should be taken with a grain
of salt but
the idea of you know putting
high fructose corn syrup in everything
salad dressing it's crazy i
i don't i don't think that's necessary
it didn't exist until the 90s i don't
think
92 is that when they invented that stuff
92. yeah what stuff
seems high fructose corn syrup i don't
know used to exist
i mean corn has been around for a while
yeah
yes we're talking about deadly so so
fallowing isn't specifically
uh you know when they're forced to but
following is when they tell the land and
then don't do anything with it so i
actually interviewed some farmers when i
was in california and they said it's a
big part of what happens is like they'll
have the people come out and tell them
okay we're gonna
foul your fields for the next amount of
time and we're gonna pay you yeah
it's like just paying them not to farm
dude i was doing understand i mean i
mean
i i think it's my initial reaction to a
lot of these things
is i might not understand but i try to
be very careful not to
take heavy actions against or for
something just because i don't
understand
so uh for instance you know trump was
paying off a lot of farmers because the
trade war was hurting a lot of the farm
industry
but the trade war was the result of us
losing many jobs and production overseas
that we needed to bring back so it
created this
ripple effect and then trump had to like
plug a hole that popped up over here
did we actually end up did the trade war
work because i'm again as a libertarian
i kind of was like i don't think the
trade war is a good idea
trade war leads to real war china's got
nukes
they're already you know getting buck
wild in the south china sea
and there's you know there's all kinds
of stuff that's going on over there
i don't know if the trade war produced
the results that we wanted to because
we're still
trillions of dollars in debt to china i
mean i mean and well
the debt just kept going up yeah
especially you know under trump but uh i
i think in one way i think one way
i can say i think we did is that a lot
of jobs were coming back
and one of the problems is we you know
we don't make our own medicine we don't
make our own vitamin c our materials
and kovid was a real slap in the face to
america i mean
it proved trump right in a lot of ways
it was last year
apparently the trump administration was
saying like we need to restore our
medical supply production back in the
u.s
you were saying it before coven way
before covington but it's been trump's
thing
yeah it's like we got to get our
factories back here's what we got to do
and so it was like some trump admin
people said it i remember i covered it
and i was like
this was in september of last year yeah
we need to bring our our
uh medical supplies back to the u.s then
covet hits and it was like
sign the executive order get it done
because we need it and so
i think even before all that one of the
reasons the economy was was doing better
and better
at least partly was you know
the the tariffs the the trade war and we
started seeing factories come back
i remember i don't know if you saw what
michael moore said in 2016 about trump
yeah
that's amazing yeah and it's it's so did
you hear it no so michael moore had this
like bit
where he went in this long he tells us
long story and he's like donald trump
went into a meeting with executives from
the auto industry
and he said to their faces i am going to
put a tariff on your vehicles of 30
and no one will buy your car ever again
if you make it overseas
and they said you know try it and trump
said i will
so these people who see trump doing this
are going to vote for him
and it will be the biggest collective fu
in history
and he says and there and they're going
to love it
for a week it'll feel good yeah it'll
feel good maybe a month
maybe a year and then like the people
who voted for brexit
they will come to regret it the best
part about that is three years later
brexit got voted on again and
won they did not regret it at all and
the people would vote for trump enjoyed
the greatest economy of our generation
so michael moore had the first part
right second part not right yeah
the the if it wasn't for covet i think
that donald trump would be
landslides i think that there's a lot of
people that
that still don't want to say positive
things about him and
and there's the general consensus that
you know it's politically incorrect to
say good things about trump
um but i do think that uh i do think
that if it wasn't for cove it'd be a
landslide and if you really look at the
covid
situation i mean i was talking to
someone on twitter the other day and i'm
like you know
back in in march and april they were
talking about
you know everyone in the country is
probably going to get it you know
75 percent of america is probably going
to get it it's super contagious
and we're going to have one percent die
so you're talking about
millions of people dying and i mean
i don't want to downplay 200 and change
thousand people dying but
if we if we look back at what was going
on
and what the conversations were that
were that were being had back then
and then look forward and come back to
now it's like 200 and change
thousand people's a whole lot less than
than a few million
yeah that's what i was thinking that's
what everyone was thinking that's what i
thought
i thought it was like we're gonna have
like i mean so
it's it's it's a spot on point there was
a new york times article where you could
add two slider bars and you could slide
up to
percent infected and mortality rate and
they were like
if this percent of people contract it
and this percent of we have this percent
of mortality
it was like 12 million people could die
and the low end was like 1.7
yeah so it sounds like based on what
they were telling us the low end
we were below the low end and that yeah
what happened worked and it's a
combination of the democrat governors
locking down and trump's efforts in
banning travel together seems like it
worked out for us
not perfectly people died what can we do
about it you know
i tell you this trump misses his cues in
these town halls in these debates
because he gets asked
why is ladies and gentlemen why is the
mortality rate per capita in the u.s
worse why are more people dying per
capita in the us than other countries
it's donald trump's fault they say
answer this oh i got a simple simple
answer for you
it's because several governors put sick
people in nursing homes killing
thousands of the elderly
crazy they didn't do that in other
countries did they and that was
democrats who did that
and now cuomo like that didn't happen i
didn't i didn't do that
i didn't kill all those people yes he
did so you know you know what i have to
think like you you mentioned this
sane rational people have memories
people who have trump derangement
syndrome have selective memories
yeah they don't they don't want to
remember any of this
i i hate to because of i have
good friends that really really hate
donald trump
and so i don't want to i don't want to
you know paint with a broad brush but
and especially because i mean
i'm i'm definitely an
outside view point when it comes to uh
the the entertainment industry
uh you know people that are in the
entertainment
industry generally do not have a
positive view of donald trump
um and i get it but like it really does
seem like you're right that
people that really don't like trump and
and
have tds or whatever uh this trump
anxiety disorder is the official term
it's an actual official yeah it's such a
it's like a clown
car on flat seriously
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you